you've had many great collaborators in
your music over the years John Legend
you work with John Legend yeah I believe
Kanye Missy Elliott the list goes on on
who's your favorite all-time
collaborator that you've worked with
favorite all-time collaborator or like
an experience you know who's talking
about experiences it would be Snoop Dogg
for obvious reasons yeah you like to
pass around gifts in the studio so you
know and you know what type of gifts I'm
talking about no I don't oh yes you do
toaster ovens yeah magic bullets
medicine you know what's interesting
we've had Andy you'll back me up on this
snoops been here many times and what
happens is he shows up with a lot of
guys and they're in their room and they
start smoking and it's in this studio
and what happens is the smoke filters
out and it gets into the audience right
where these people are right now and
every time he's kind of and then I come
out to do the monologue and they're
laughing before I tell the joke so they
catch a second yeah a second Hannah yeah
it's actually fantastic IDs better than
an applause sign so suits are both of
our favorite collaborators Snoop Dogg
snoop Dogg there you have it so you were
with him you were and and you saw him
because he smokes more than you think is
humanly possible he absolutely does and
I was with a friend of mine who I knows
that you know who I know that smokes
more than anyone I can remotely think of
and for the first time in my life after
about an hour of smoking I saw this guy
turned down the weed turn it down really
turned down the smoke and I was just
like it was a moment in history for me
because you saw him he talked over to me
and my guys just went like this all
right come on no more I can do no more
yeah
you